you have just graduated from university
and you just got hired by tesla after a
few weeks on the job you have just built
your first
autonomous car and you are ready to test
it on the road
so you take it to the nearest highway to
test drive it
at time t equals zero you launch the car
from the position x0 equals zero
with a constant speed of 60 kilometers
per hour
now being a good engineer you want to
track the position
and speed of the car at regular
intervals for example
every hour you want to know where your
car is
in a perfect world tracking the car
would be a piece of cake
the speed of the car would be constant
60 kilometers per hour
and its position at time t plus one
would simply be its position at time t
plus the speed times delta t
usually we like to write these types of
equations in matrix and
vector format for convenience so the
car's position and speed
will evolve according to the simple
linear dynamical system
if the last year of 2020 is anything to
go by
the word is actually far from perfect
your initial estimates for the speed and
position of the car
are probably not perfectly accurate for
instance
the speedometer that you use might give
you noisy measurements of the speed
you check the manual provided by the
manufacturer for the measuring
instruments that you use
and you find that the measurements that
you get are noisy and the noise can be
modeled by some gaussian variable
with the following covariance matrix the
way to interpret this matrix
sigma zero is that it represents your
uncertainty about the state
of the system the first diagonal element
represents the uncertainty that you have
about the position of the car
and the second diagonal element
represents your uncertainty
about the speed the off-diagonal
elements
represent the correlation between noise
in measurements
to the speed and to the position of the
car another problem you might face
is that the conditions on the road are
not perfect
especially if you live in california
meaning that the nominal dynamical
system
that governs the movement of the car
might get perturbed
we like to model this kind of
perturbances as gaussian noise
with a known covariance matrix that we
call p
all right now an hour has passed
what would be your best guess for where
the car position is right now
and what is your guess for the car's
speed
you could say let me ignore all the
imperfections of the world
and follow this idealized dynamical
system
and see where it leads me the math in
this case is
pretty simple the car would remain at
the constant speed of 60 kilometer per
hour
and after one hour it would be one
kilometer away
from the starting position now all of a
sudden
you remember something you actually have
a gps installed in the car
and that gps can give you measurements
of the position of the car
every hour perfect you check the gps
data
and it's telling you that the car is 0.8
kilometer away
from the starting position this gps
however
does not measure the speed of the car so
now
here is a question which one of these
two measurements
would you trust more the one you have
predicted by ignoring all the
imperfections of the word
or the estimate that you obtained from
your measuring instruments
more interestingly though can you
combine both of these estimates
to get a new estimate that is more
accurate
than both estimates individually for
instance
if you had to guess you would say that
the true position of the car
is probably between the 0.8 and one
kilometer mark
and as a consequence the speed of the
car should probably be lower
than 60 kilometers per hour but how much
less than 60 kilometers per hour exactly
and we're exactly in the interval 0.81
would you say the car's position is
right now as you might have guessed
the answer probably depends on what we
know about the size of the noise
in our initial estimates in our
measuring instruments
in our model of the dynamical system of
the car
the answer to this question is what
kalman filters are all about
as we will see a kalman filter is an
algorithm for estimating the state of
the system
for example the speed and position of
the car using past
and possibly noisy observations and
current
and possibly noisy measurements of that
system
more specifically let's say that this is
the underlying dynamical system and
let's say
that this is the measurement that we get
so
at every time t we get a measurement
there is a random variable
yt so you can see that yt is a linear
function
of the state xt plus some noise b that
we model
as a random gaussian variable with a
known covariance matrix q
in the toe example we just saw h was the
row vector 1 0
because the only thing we measured
through the gps
is the position and that was the first
component
of our state vector xt kelman filtering
is a two-step process here is how it
works
the first step is called the prediction
step
in this step you take whatever prior
estimates you had about the
state of the system you run these
estimates
through the idealized version of the
dynamical system
and that would be your prediction for
the state of the system at the next time
step
i'm going to mark these estimates with a
minus sign upper script
the reason i do that is because this
will not be our final estimate
since we have not yet incorporated the
information that we get
from our measuring instruments another
important thing we have to do in this
prediction step
is to think about how our noise
covariance matrix
propagates through the system in the
case where we have
perfect estimates of our state variables
i.e when sigma t is zero
the only uncertainty is going to come
from the perturbation
to our dynamical system ie from the
matrix p
in general though sigma t would not be
zero
so when you run this sigma t through the
idealized
system and you work out the math you
realize
that we need to add an additional term a
sigma
a transpose so what does this mean for
our
toy example well in the prediction step
we simply predict that the car would be
in this yellow spot
so now the question is how can i
incorporate
the additional information i get from my
measuring instruments
to update and improve this prediction
that is done in the second step of
kalman filtering
which is appropriately called the update
step
in this step we take the results of our
prediction
in terms of the state of the system and
the covariance matrix of the noise
and we take the new measurements that we
made about the system
which are noisy remember and we combine
both in a single estimate which would be
our final estimate of the system
so how does this work what we need to
compute
is the surprise term the surprise term
is the difference between
what you have predicted and what you
have measured
the larger this term is the more
surprised you are
and the more you question everything
that you learned in university
now you look at this picture and you
need to decide by how much
you need to correct your prediction
based on the surprise term
and for that you need to see how much
you trust your prediction
which is measured by this covariance
matrix and how much you trust
you're measuring instruments which is
measured by this
covariance matrix more precisely
you need to compute this ratio sometimes
called
a kalman ratio the sigma term is your
uncertainty about your prediction
for the position and this q term is your
uncertainty about the
gps measurements this ratio is always
between -1
and 1. if it is 0 it means that the
sigma term is 0
meaning that you have complete faith in
the predictions you made
so you are basically saying my car is in
the yellow spot
on the other hand if it is 1 it means
that the q
term is 0 which means that you
completely trust
your gps and you're saying that the car
is in the blue spot
in practice though this ratio will be
somewhere between 0 and 1.
so what you do is that you take your
prediction
and you correct it with the term k
times the surprise term delta x the
bigger the ratio
the bigger the correction so this is how
we correct
our prediction for the position but now
how do we correct our prediction for the
speed of the car
remember our gps does not measure the
speed
at all so we need to somehow use what we
know about
another state variable the position to
infer how to correct our prediction for
the speed
and this is the magic of kalman filters
you do not need to measure everything
all the time
partial measurements are still okay so
what is the correct kalman coefficient
to use here
you look at a common coefficient that is
very similar
to what we had before except that now
the numerator
is replaced by the off diagonal term
sigma x x dot which represents the
correlation
between speed and position and this
makes sense
this is the term you want to use to
convert an information about the
position
to any information about the speed in
the worst case
if the noise in the speed and position
are independent from each other this
ratio will be zero
which means that what we know about the
position of the car
would be completely useless as far as
the speed is concerned
and there is an identical formula for
correcting our prediction for the speed
more generally going back to the general
formula
you get the following equations for
correcting your predictions
for the state of the system and the
covariance matrix of the notes
there are two things i'm not doing here
i'm not telling you how to derive these
two expressions in full detail
and i'm not telling you how to compute
this common term k
which is a matrix in the more general
case
there are countless references online
including wikipedia for that
and i believe that you are in an
excellent position to follow what's
happening there
if you have understood the intuition of
kalman filters
explained in this video thank you very
much and
see you next time